I apologize for the romanticized
question but what what idea in the space
of neural size in the space of the human
brain is to use the most beautiful
mysterious surprising what what had
always fascinated me even when I was a
pretty young kid I think was the the the
paradox that lies in the fact that the
brain is so mysterious and so in seem so
distant but at the same time it's
responsible for the the the the full
transparency of everyday life it's the
brain is literally what makes everything
obvious and familiar and and and there's
always one in the room with you yeah I I
used to teach when I taught at Princeton
I used to teach a cognitive neuroscience
course and the very last thing I would
say to the students was you know people
often when people think of scientific
inspiration the the metaphor is often
will look to the stars you know the
stars will inspire you to wonder at the
universe and and you know think about
your place in it and how things work and
and I'm all for looking at the stars but
I've always been much more inspired and
my sense of wonder comes from the not
from the distant mysterious stars but
from the extremely intimately close
brain yeah there's something just
endlessly fascinating to me about that
the like just like you said the the the
one is close and yet distant in in terms
of our understanding of it do you are
you all so captivated by the the fact
that this very conversation is happening
because two brains are communicating the
I guess what I mean is the subjective
nature of the experience if we can take
a small taejun into
the the mystical of it the consciousness
or or when you are saying you're
captivated by the idea of the brain are
you talking about specifically the
mechanism of cognition or are you also
just like at least for me it's almost
like paralyzing the beauty and the
mystery of the fact that it creates the
entirety of the experience not just the
reasoning capability but the experience
well I I definitely resonate with that
that latter thought and I I often find
discussions of artificial intelligence
to be disappointingly narrow you know
speaking of someone who has always had
an interest in in in art great it was
just gonna go there because it sounds
like somebody who has an interest in art
yeah I mean I there there there there
are many layers to you know to full bore
human experience and and in some ways
it's not enough to say oh well don't
worry you know we were talking about
cognition but we'll add emotion you know
yeah there's there's there's an
incredible scope to what humans go
through in in every moment and and yes
so it's that's part of what fascinates
me is that is that our brains are
producing that but at the same time it's
so mysterious to us how okay we
literally our brains are literally in
our heads producing this experience and
yet there and yet there's there it's so
mysterious to us and so and in the
scientific challenge of getting at the
the the actual explanation for that is
so overwhelming that's just I don't know
that
certain people have fixations on
particular questions and that's always
that's just always been mine yeah I
would say the poetry that is fascinating
and I'm really interested in natural
language as well and when you look at
our personal intelligence community it
always
saddens me how much when you try to
create a benchmark for the community
together around how much of the magic of
language is lost when you create that
benchmark that there is something would
we talk about experience the the music
of the language the wit the something
that makes a rich experience something
that would be required to pass the
spirit of the Turing test is lost in
these benchmarks and I wonder how to get
it back in because it's very difficult
the moment you tried to do like real
good rigorous science you lose some of
that magic when you try to study
cognition in a rigorous scientific way
he feels like you're losing some of the
magic mm-hmm-hmm the the seen cognition
in a mechanistic way that AI folk at
this stage in our history well okay I I
agree with you
but at the same time one-one thing that
I found really exciting about that first
wave of deep learning models in
cognition was there was the the fact
that the people who were building these
models were focused on the richness and
complexity of human cognition so an
early debate in cognitive science which
I sort of witnessed as a grad student
was about something that sounds very dry
which is the formation of the past tense
but there were these two camps one said
well the the mind encodes certain rules
and it also has a list of exceptions
because of course you know the rule is a
DB but that's not always what you do so
you have to have a list of exceptions
and and then there were the
connectionists who you know evolved into
the deep learning people who said well
you know if you look carefully at the
data if you look at actually look at
corpora like language corpora it's it
turns out to be very rich because yes
there are there are there's a you know
the your most verbs that and you know
you just tack on e d and then there are
exceptions but there are also there's
also there are there rule
that in you know there's the exceptions
aren't just random they there are
certain clues to which which which verbs
should be exceptional and then there are
so exceptions to the exceptions and
there was a word that was kind of
deployed in order to capture this which
was quasi regular in other words there
are rules but it's it's messy and there
there's their structure even among the
exceptions and and it would be yeah you
could try to write down we could try to
write down this structure in some sort
of closed form but really the right way
to understand how the brain is handling
all this and by the way producing all of
this is to build a deep neural network
and trained it on this data and see how
it ends up representing all of this
richness so the way that deep learning
was deployed in cognitive psychology was
that was the spirit of it it was about
that richness and that's something that
I always found very very compelling
still do
you